it makes me wonder LSU will begin with
you where the Bill Gross is right that
the party's over
right and not just in Europe but
everywhere risk asset prices are going
to drop this year I could agree with
part of that view but let me qualify
where I would disagree where I agree is
that all these low interest rates and QE
doesn't really do anything to
resuscitate growth if you do not have
fiscal stimulus the reason being because
you are in a balance sheet recession in
the private sector both corporations and
consumers especially in Europe are not
in a mode to take on debt sometimes they
can't even and so in an economy things
have to adapt if two major agents of the
economy if the private sector is saving
somebody else has to spend to sustain
the economy and if that's not the
government through fiscal spending
you're gonna go into a deflationary trap
surprise that's exactly where we are
after four years of these policies of
austerity in the eurozone right you go
through a steady you achieve primary
surpluses but GDP collapses debt to GDP
ratios are higher today than they were
before all these sacrifices were made so
we know in Italy Renzi has been pushing
with Merkel for a little bit of leeway
on these austerity policies of a target
of fiscal plan fiscal spending plan and
I think the vote in Greece is exactly
about that syriza is getting some
support because they want to talk about
renegotiating these austerity measures
so Simon is that is what Alessio is
saying beginning to I guess become the
prevailing view in Europe that while
Draghi talks about the need for further
monetary stimulus at the ECB it may
accomplish next to nothing because
yields on the bonds that the ECB
presumably would be buying are already
well under 2% and in some cases near
zero yeah absolutely bang for the buck
that a Mario Draghi's QE program if he
indeed executes Swan is is undermined by
the fact that bond yields are so much
lower much lower than where where yields
were in the UK and the US where no
central banks started to buy bonds and
so yes certainly they
the the impact from a buying in in
Europe is already diminished by the fact
that yields have fallen so low there the
ability to to get them much lowers is
greatly reduced so if the ECB were to
engage in quantitative easing and it
appears as though it will what's the net
result going to be where's all that
where's that money going to end up out
of the so the so here's it yeah let's
not forget Draghi at the last Jackson
Hole speech in August he specifically
said we can accomplish some but we need
reforms and fiscal stimulus so drag is
onboard the ECB knows that without
fiscal spending the impact of QE of QE
on growth will be limited so as of now
where is that money gonna go
well the eurozone has a massive current
account surplus there has been growing
because of shrinking domestic demand
what that means capital account outflows
what that means and we're seen it in the
balance of payments equity outflows
fixed income outflows so local Europeans
have enough buying power to buy local
fixed income but there is excess savings
that is leaking out of the eurozone and
going where everywhere Europeans love
fixed income assets much more than
equities the asset allocation of
European private investors is on average
about 80 percent fixed is that 20
percent
institutional preferences institutional
regulations but if you look globally the
biggest equity players in the world is
us investors Japanese a Europeans are
much more tilted towards spread product
they have a little lower risk appetite
lower propensity to take on risk so
where is that money going US Treasuries
where is that money going US Treasuries
with dollar exposure the dollar Israel
in the u.s. falling Treasury yields are
falling and retesting 2% falling below
2% despite us growth having accelerated
over the last six months they're going
to Japan they're going everywhere that's
why also emerging market yields while
underperforming develop markets but they
are still very well contained I mean the
fact that Italy can borrow 2 percent at
the same levels of the United States it
tells you about there is no shortage of
appetite for
fixed-income securities that's why Kiwi
you know itself is not needed to lower
yields heels are already going low by
themselves where is that money gonna go
that's the big question I think more
credit more spread products anything we
they yield anything with duration will
continue to be very well supported the
Simon is there any chance that the ECB
is a result of what you've said in what
Alessio has explained we'll consider
something other than quantitative easing
does it have any options or is Draghi
now effectively Merkel's prisoner it has
lots of options that whether it executes
stem I think Draghi at the last press
conference before the holidays pointed
out that apart from gold that's very
little that they wouldn't consider I'd
throw the euro and I doubt they're gonna
at this point start intervening to
weaken the year I think need to see a
full-scale currency war if that was the
case but there's this corporate bonds
there's other products out there but he
seems very he's very much over his skis
now the the signs and the hints are that
it will be sovereign debt he looks to
buy but perhaps only only 500 billions
worth of that and and he does want as
we've pointed out the government's to
assist his system in structural forms
and fiscal spending whether you'll see
that is another thing though so that
being the case Alessio the euro trading
right now at more or less Bach 18 buck
19 where does it go I think given how
easily we broke through 120 the momentum
seems very powerful and momentum with
very little volatility so 110-115 seemed
the easy psychological threshold I'm
powerful in terms of doing what the how
the chart shows that the the euro
bearish trend has been very steady
powerful in the sense that he hasn't had
any setbacks he hasn't scared anybody
out with big Corrections it looks very
similar to the yen's sell-off that we
had a couple of years ago you know one
thing that I noticed yesterday and I'm
sorry we don't have a chart to
illustrate it but Simon knows what I'm
talking about
the decline in the Euro matches up not
quite perfectly but very closely to the
decline in
Brent why are they so trading in such
lockstep so there's two components one
is the traditional negative relationship
between the dollar and oil yeah which we
can debate there are several channels
several strong channels I think it's a
legitimate relationship but additionally
I think there is this QE component now
because with the eurozone and Germany at
zero inflation this deflationary shock
coming from oil is only going to
exacerbate the deflationary pressure on
the euro zone and therefore strengthen
the case that drag has always made about
QE so I think I think that's that's a
very powerful relationship and if you
were to scale it to two relative axes he
would look much nicer that's what I had
right yesterday exactly the relationship
is almost intraday tick for ticks so
Draghi and the Germans in particular
terrified about deflation Draghi and
paradoxically Greece I think now have it
easy because because Draghi
angry's can prove look austerity led us
yes now deflation is knocking at the
doorstep of the Germans so so that the
Simon can answer this question how long
Simon does it take for the Germans to
wake up and realize that they're wrong
if in fact that's the case well they
would take a different round maybe
sterically after the second world has
worked and that any fruits that's been
born I think the phrase by their the
finance minister last week in Greece our
result of that the policies they pushed
and yet at the same time yo you're
seeing the inflation in Germany two five
year low they can't contain that there
is a limit to how much how much they
like inflation to fall and so perhaps
now in more than the last year say the
the the opposition to QE minton might
not be as great as it once was